32 seconds of waterlogged water no
ghosts oh thank God for a minute there I
thought that was gonna be a movie about
deep blue something we'd have to sit
through a hundred minutes of Breakfast
at Tiffany's I don't think I could
relive 1995 all over again a minute into
the proceedings and movie is imitation
drowsing so hard that I can't tell if
it's an homage a parody or a blatant
ripoff since all three of those have
been done to death here's a sin for each
of the possibilities yeah woman said she
hears seas feel something and her horny
boyfriend thinks it has something to do
with sex but it's not because it's a
scary monster cliche is every character
in this going to nonchalantly narrate
all their actions I'm getting my leg bit
off man a shark just booting my hand bro
actually I might have joined that better
if this movie goes full dude where's my
arm I guarantee you it's an improvement
it is said the charts can detect line in
the water up to a mile away that's what
makes them such dangerous alcoholic
predators our pool next shark anut also
later we find out that the lab has no
real clue how the shark got out so how
did they even know the shark was gone
and where when enough time to save these
horny teens I don't care how harpoon
that shark is there was no way these two
would just be sitting in the water and
not continuing to panic swim their way
back onto the boat in a slow news day
national newspapers ran with the shark
almost eats teenager story also it's
good to see that there's at least one
firm out there helping victims deal with
anyone's the clam doctor the 200 million
had sunk in this company is doing great
part to your research I'll add this
wealthy suit could remind Susan of the
exact amount of money he's sunk into the
company for maximum clunkiness 200,000
men and women develop out Simas each
year you gotta love a movie that is all
about sharks eating people trying to
make its story matter by throwing
Alzheimer's into it give me till Monday
morning arbitrary timeframe is arbitrary
but what I'm really wondering about is
why is Ronny Cox aka ko Hagan from Total
Recall even here he didn't get one line
it's clear Sam Jackson is the real boss
here but I guess this company is still
old fashioned and needs the appearance
of an old white guy running things could
give you a big kiss you could remove
that no there is no way you've
transported her here without sedating
her so why wouldn't you take that out on
the journey so how much do you know
about our facility treat me like a
tourist that way you'll have an excuse
to exposition the spannabis
and then we talked about the license
plate a minute ago but is the whole
reason why this guy jumped into a shark
tank so that he could get this license
plate out of its mouth done is issue but
in a pet shop
Baton Rouge ate everything in his fish
tank then he ate the guy that bought him
I can't decide which are more boring and
pointless the stories these characters
tell or the characters themselves
actually they don't like the taste of us
very much
they bite yeah it's because they think
you're fat little seal well it doesn't
give me much confidence I mean whether
or not they don't like the taste of you
is immaterial they can confuse you with
a seal you got full sentences usually he
just kind of nods and I choose a third
option where he's not in the movie it's
pretty scary stuff huh
yes it is yes I am scared my heart is
beating very fast shall we discuss again
how scary it is they're going home we
run a skeleton crew on the weekend after
a long week at work and seeing the same
faces every day I'm not buying the party
atmosphere on this boat grumbles and
mumbles seem much more likely than music
and dancing these fences off the water
eight feet give or take a centimeter I'm
all for progressive unions but you've
officially gone too far when you're
mixing standard English measurements
with the metric system that's just not
the way God intended it sighs the half a
mile of catwalks you bought us titanium
based fencing around all the lagoon and
pins let me tell you more about the
things that you already know but the
audience doesn't there's nothing that
says your movie is from 1999 more than
when you see stuff like this you know
like saffron burrows when the word
started flashing on the screen I thought
it was your typical movie computer data
but it turns out these are the words to
an article about the brain I know this
is some 1999 web page nonsense I don't
remember or the filmmakers made these
words fly onto the screen to look cool
why would you open this and get sent to
the middle of the article in man yeah
I'm the man Warner Brothers somehow
advertised his future samuel l.jackson
movies six years in advance as LL Cool J
hitting on this bird I guess he really
does need love are we supposed to
believe that shark cannibalism is the
only way to feed these monsters even if
it was I doubt a group of marine
biologists with a deep love of animals
would let it happen
[Music]
we'll be waste time with a surprise
birthday party when they should be deep
blue seeing already we haven't seen one
human death yet and my bloodlust is
killing me I sure hope they find my
Pierre to Alzheimer's though how's life
underwater well it's a lot less
complicated than it is on the surface
that's for sure I swear the dialogue in
this movie is like passing a kidney
stone it takes forever for anyone to say
anything and when they finally do
there's so little substance to it that
you can't believe how much pain it
causes one day I'd have to tell me how
you learned that one day you'll take me
up on that beer and maybe I will you
can't have a shark or dinosaur movie
without the movies Wrangler hitting on
the hot chick in charge
they don't have a history or this would
be a skipped basis fences like I asked
it's okay can you not see for yourself
that the fences have been raised or did
Tom raise them so minimally that Carter
can tell they recognize that gun sigh
did you not just say a minute ago by
using a hormonal enhancer we increase
this females forebrain to five times its
normal size
isn't it possible that your brain
testing is causing the Sharks to learn
new skills might a movie scientists
always say that's impossible when they
see right in front of their face it's
hilarious that the Sharks have figured
out the concept of surveillance cameras
just because they have bigger brains now
and it's even funnier that they disabled
the first two cameras without being seen
but on the last one one of these sharks
appears fully on screen to confirm that
they were the ones behind it all
just minutes ago these sharks were smart
enough to hunt together recognize a gun
and take out cameras but now this one
attacks an empty scuba tank all alone
apparently the Sharks intelligence is on
a plot based timing system how exactly
did Carter get this giant sedated shark
from where he was to here guessing they
aren't exactly easy to move underwater
also what was the original plan to get
her on this loading platform that didn't
involve Carter free swimming through
shark territory he had to have some sort
of plan right if I know my marine
biology man I'm sure I don't
shark skin is not smooth like a dolphins
but scaly and sharp so swimmy Carter
here should be cutting up his hand
trying to pet it she's sleeping like a
baby these assholes continue to
underestimate how smart these sharks are
despite all the evidence and their
scientists which makes it worse I'm
adding five sins for the stupidity
remember was it the Meissner or the
Stanislavski acting technique that
included reacting to everything with an
over-the-top double date whichever it is
these actors are obviously thoroughly
trained in it there are so many hard
stairs in this movie I swear Paddington
is lurking somewhere nearby to teach me
a heartfelt lesson introducing two cc's
of the protein complex into cultured
inactive brain neurons of an outsider's
patient
god bless movie science just suck some
cerebrum Druce from the shark and plop
it on a chunk of Alzheimer's brain to do
a test who needs all those silly
in-between steps right
oh that's gonna leave a nasty skarsgrd
scar scar also goes to show that curing
Alzheimer's cost an arm enough we know
at least an arm why is the only option a
gun that's kept behind glass shouldn't
Carter have another tranq ready to go is
this really the standard emergency
procedure Jesus does preacher even get
to go to his quarters this guy is in the
kitchen 24/7 what's he even doing here
right now
these sharks learned the concept of
murder while swimming around in a tank
getting bigger brains also let's break
down this nonsense piece by piece
shall we first how is Professor Selvig
still alive that breathing apparatus
isn't meant for water use he's lost a
lot of blood and it's been underwater at
least three minutes at the very least
this man should be passed out second I
don't care how fast that shark is moving
you can't throw a sidelong projectile
with that much surface area through
water at all as soon as discount Bruce
attempts to mouths javelin his toy
through the window it would immediately
stop and sink third even if that scars
dirt somehow made it to the window with
full force it's not going to crack glass
built to withstand the pressure of that
depth of water and fourth what's the
actual movie this is a lesson about the
drinking a local day comic relief feels
like that's the only reason he's here
and why he's separated from the others
so the movie can cut to him talking to
God or his parrot it's as if the movies
plot itself and Michael Rapaport wasn't
enough what the hell is that
so this noise is supposed to be a shark
trying to open this door is that what we
were being led to believe here how did
the shark even know they would be here
and at this very moment did the shark
set up some sort of closed-circuit
viewing system to watch their prey you
know what in this movie why not
yeah that's pretty damn obvious we don't
know what they're doing yet oh come on
you've seen more than enough evidence to
know that they're actively trying to
kill you and probably escaped to things
they've already successfully done in
this picture now maybe you don't know
what they plan to do is build nuclear
weapons and invade Mars but the
short-term goal here is to kill you and
escape Jim and I use gene therapies to
increase that brain mass as a side
effect the shots gotten smarter how
smart were the Sharks before today one
escaped earlier to attack the teen's
while the others sat back and kicked it
in the shark tank
drinking margaritas but as soon as
Russell shows up and susan has 48 hours
to prove to him their work is going
somewhere they suddenly know they never
knew before what you've done is not this
all the way to the bottom of the goddamn
food chain below rabbits who would have
thought that 20 years later a floating
playboy would make me think of politics
and Pietschmann and hush money instead
of other stuff
LL Cool J easily outruns a super shark
in water I'm not even sure LL Cool J
could outrun a shark on Land Shark BL B
does not include Terminator style data
flashing on the screen so what the shots
get through the fence and into the ocean
it's okay the fence on the ocean side is
titanium wait did they forget about the
beginning of this movie where one of
their shirts got into the ocean and they
never figured out how this asshole
without fail has said something like
phat buck to LL Cool J the entire movie
but now that he's climbing some shelves
he decided to be quiet until it was time
to be a jump scaring dick there was this
much gas in the room to create an
explosion well I didn't everything blow
as soon as he lit the zipper it's at
this point that LL Cool J might have
considered a slight name change
although LL he J and now L burn J don't
quite have the ring do they get that
close suggestion shadowing holy what a
great death scene the whole movie makes
Russell out to be the potential hero of
this movie because he saved some people
from an avalanche then he's eaten and it
is even Telegraph me this is probably
all you remember about this movie
I wasn't even aware that vacuums
operated on a three-second delay for
dramatic timing good to know the idea
that these two could close this door
with this amount of water rushing in is
as likely as a sarcastic youtube channel
stopping disney from owning all of pop
culture
[Music]
once again I'm unsure of what kind of
GPS these sharks are using that they
know exactly where the humans are and
what they're doing I haven't seen
supernatural chasing this ridiculous
since the tornados went Helen hunting on
twister hero stuff blah blah blah scary
sharks blah blah blah saved the day blah
blah pad the run time big real big
what's that if you're gonna tell someone
they have brass balls who goes through
the trouble of saying you're big real
big
so that the guy has to play a guessing
game as to what that means she's been
bobbing in this water for a few seconds
now and somehow the super intelligent
shark that has been stalking them
non-stop hasn't eaten his Jan sandwich
yet it's not like there's anywhere for
the shark to go is it taking a nap
because of severe shark alep see is
there a reason why Janice can't swim
over to the part of the ladder that
isn't broken climb up it and get to
where they aren't there is the movie
saying the current is too strong for her
to make that move no worries Jan the
water was rising so quickly before that
it should get you up to that ladder in
no time what's that oh sorry
Jan apparently the laws of physics have
an on and off switch that corresponds
with the need for dramatic tension tough
luck close-up shocked face close-up sad
face close-up dumb face seriously the
movie is so obsessed with these
continuous faces of death reaction shots
it might as well have been sponsored by
Apple FaceTime fancy meeting I mean
convenient meeting you here Jan is a
healthy girl something means it has run
on batteries when most of your friends
have been shark food and you're afraid
for your life I always find that a bit
of my dead friend's vibrator humor is
exactly the thing to bring hope back to
the situation sharks I think it's been
established that these sharks smell wine
in the water so you should be good
one night a whole week to grab hold of a
half and a second could seem like an ass
on a hot woman never can seem like a
second indeed early Einstein equations
included pictures of large breasts on a
chalkboard it would later just be DM in
e equals MC squared also e equals MC
Hammer squared I spent four years at
Caltech and that's the best physics
explanation I've ever heard not exactly
a ringing endorsement for Caltech then
is it we got one who's
sharks left thanks for the sharks
position and all but it's not as if this
movie has done any work helping us
understand what each of the three sharks
were doing at any given moment
honestly except for the fact that one
appeared to fry in the oven they might
as well all be the same shark about that
date or everyone dying isn't just tragic
yes fish death is always useless doctor
everything in this movie they've given
out all cool j2se sounds like the type
of thing you've nod your head and smoke
some more weed and agreement too but
then the next day you'd be like damn
none of that is true at all and everyone
the Taco Bell will be wondering what the
you're yelling about stellan skarsgrd
michael rip apart okay I'm done also six
years after Jurassic Park and this is
the best we can do this is the fakest
michael rapaport his looks and see was
Joey the raccoon and dr. Dolittle - wow
look at that preach just conveniently
convenient at the same convenient place
as he convenience before ladies and
gentlemen it's the rare convenient
appearance double down let's never make
it out of situations like this
situations are racist on a classic
dorsal fin fake out every shark movie
has one and none of them since jaws feel
original in the slightest this is sort
of the worst aspect of this movie there
are two sharks but they seem to be
covering impossible ground throughout
the entire sea lap and what happened to
those sharks working together
wasn't it a big deal when they notice
the Sharks were in sync with each other
they've split up since they entered the
lab and none of that has mattered at all
movies were attractive people's clothing
is always needed for something more
important than wearing guys after this
movie it's gonna be awfully hard to get
wood if I can't see a shark getting
electrocuted in fact I've checked the
Box on my eHarmony account that says
must own multiple disposable sharks for
sexual purposes sharks are ejected
turning water bright colors these
extinguishers should be a distraction
sure but you turn these guys all super
kill a Frank and shark expert ala genius
remember why would any other normal
shark rules even apply to them that's to
bring up too fast your lungs will pop
like a balloon you want the sunny kid in
your class where you what kind of
situation do you think this is dude were
you expecting the Tom Jane Comedy Hour
here weren't you the guy who was all
business a minute ago when you said you
wanted to get the fuck out of here
maybe I'm harping too much of this comic
relief character but damn there's a time
to switch it off and this is it dive
ride advice
so clearly your mouth didn't say surely
there oh sure you were about to say it
but the sound guy jumped the gun in the
editing and I'm the meatus mother made
the valley one thing I know about God is
that he loves when people say
motherfucker in the middle of a prayer
it shows that you're engaged that you
mean it these sharks have torn arms off
and ripped people in half of one chomp
but now they decided to just drag LL
Cool J around for a while why the sudden
need to play with their food okay but
didn't he lose like a human-sized pool
of blood during that attack he pled out
for like a full minute they've been
hurting us pushing us where they want
using us to flood the facility oh they
did not the only reason the lamb flooded
was because the helicopters towing cable
broke off and threw Jim into the water
then the Sharks used his body to break
the glass it's not for that one thing
that was completely unrelated to the
Sharks they would have never flooded the
facility also intelligence does not
equal knowledge even if you made the
shark super intelligent they wouldn't
have the architectural scientific or
psychological knowledge to understand
even a portion of the things they needed
to know to execute that plan the freedom
that's deep blue sea roll credits from
up here you ought to be able to see me
spirit when I do you take this end of
this cable hook it up to the positive
side of the boat battery and boom sounds
like you've been thinking about this
long before you ever had to do it you're
a sick Carter ocean just like seven
years bad tetanus also Hollywood's been
doing fake blood for almost a century
now you think they could do better than
this cherry pie felling nonsense that's
the second time a ladder is broken
during this movie Russell Franklin
invested a ton in this facility but one
place where he cheaped out was ladder
safety that shark just roar underwater
wait a minute did preacher know the plan
about the harpoon and the battery wasn't
you out of your shot and sleeping during
that conversation or is he a kook who
also knows a lot about blowing up sharks
with harpoon battery compost some
incredibly lucky bull allows Carter to
free himself with a harpoon and keep it
lodged in the shark somehow
I don't know if Carter could to find
this but I'm sitting it anyway also I
don't even have the energy anymore to
dissect the science of wet water battery
conductive flare gunpowder or giant
shark explosions shark goes boom can I
go home now deepest bluest my hat is
like a shark's fin live by these words
gents
I don't know exactly when we turned on
each other I just know that seven of us
survived the slide and only five made it
out I know what people taste like I know
the babies taste best
[Music]
[Applause]
sharks still looks fake just keep
swimming